here's what i here's the prediction from
mike glover who runs field craft
survival and and does this for a living
looking at preparedness looking at
threats
um it's my academic experience it's also
my counterterrorism counterintelligence
experience
on
during the election cycle
we will see
uh a massive disruption
and on election night prior and after
you will see
a
what feels like civil war and heavily in
the next few months in the next few
years okay because we're going to have a
lead up all the social media platforms
are going to start getting leverage the
the troll farms from china russia north
korea's influence will start affecting
us like it did with blm and antifa and
the election cycle and what you're going
to see up is a lead up attention
and and and what you're seeing is
politician
irresponsibly weaponizing government
agencies and people
and what you're going to see and
especially in heavy populated areas
is what looks like a civil war you're
going to see imagine this scenario you
have antifa and blm it comes out like
they did and they start burning down the
streets except now you're going to have
the right fringe who's going to come out
and go we won't accept this it's not
just that during the summer of love
locals just a political people were seen
standing on their street corners with
rifles 100 so so then you have this this
imbalance where you have
leftist extremists right right-wing
extremist and then the people in the
middle just defending what they own
their families their friends their
communities and then all of these things
are happening and then it starts
bleeding into the outskirts it starts
affecting everybody but what happens
when
the law enforcement officers are caught
in the middle
now
are they not supposed to defend their
lives they're in the middle of an active
gunfight so take the written house
situation and amplify that in a full
skirmish where the battlefield are the
streets of densely populated areas like
chicago where you come from so uh you've
seen beaver vendetta yes yeah i wanna
just
just think of that scene at the end
where the guy says eventually someone
will do something stupid and it shows
the finger man the cop shoot the little
girl
all of the local residents just walk up
with weapons and they go after that cop
and then it like camera pans up and he
goes ah like they're no longer going to
tolerate law enforcement
i think it won't be over something like
that but you'll get to the point like
you mentioned a written situation
we've already seen circumstances where
people have beaten cops where cops are
caught in a riot and then if it gets to
the point where
these riders are unscrupulous and just
literally don't care anymore
then you're going to get a v from
vendetta-like situation there will be a
riot the cop will come out and he'll be
telling people to get away they won't
he'll fire probably less lethal and then
they'll just start clobbering on them
so
you you uh we we often uh talk about
particularly with people who've
experienced war you know our friend
forrest cooper mentions the people who
are trained in war and who've
experienced it are the ones begging you
to stop because they don't want to see
this happen
i've not been in war i've been in civil
conflict and unrest so precursors too
the worst thing i've seen was people in
egypt shooting at each other with
makeshift they had these pistols that
were like 12 they were
12 gauge i think uh and they would
single shot you break barrel break
action put it in close it bang
and from
atop the hilton i watched someone get
shot killed and then their body was
carried away that was the one time in in
this reporting i've seen someone just
deliberately be killed in front of me
not in front of me like very relatively
close but i was high up so i was safe we
were fair we were all pretty safe
and that experience was like
having covered some of the unrest riots
fires i was i was on west florissant and
ferguson when they were burning down the
entirety of that whole block you drove
your car down the street the fires were
so intense in your car it felt like the
fire was right in front of your face
seeing that
and knowing that's not even warfare
i can't imagine you know like i'll just
ask you like what do you think the
average person would do if they actually
were you know forced into the fray of
people engaging in a firefight in there
in their neighborhood or something yeah
so you know war is a tends to be a
complex thing but in the primal like the
ancestral version of it's very simple i
mean it's very simple it's it's violence
it's chaos
the people who are trained for war my
peer group who are trained for war go
into war with intent meeting tasks
uh purpose and objectives
it and so when you have that and and you
understand what that is
it it's demonstrated in this idea of art
of war right we understand how to
operate more people who have not who
people who are so fragile they can't
change their tire in a fender bender
they lose their mind
a simple emergency emergency trauma they
they lose their mind where somebody
actually pays for their life when
something so simple could have been done
that's the world we live in because
we're we're living in that you know
what's really crazy to me so when i did
the uh the hostile environment training
they had to explain to people how to
apply a tourniquet and to put it over
the wound so like
they did this okay so we have a dummy
here he's got a bleed in his leg and
people were like where does a tourniquet
go they would put it under and they're
like it has to go above and i'm like yes
otherwise it's not stopping the blood
between the heart and the wound yeah i
don't underst i think that's that's it
it was crazy to me that people didn't
understand that we actually had one guy
when they showed a video of a femoral
bleed he fainted
and then i was just thinking to myself
like
what would have happened to this guy you
know he's in his neighborhood
violence war conflict breaks out we're
in such a safe era here in the united
states if he saw
a a modicum of the violence that our
troops had experienced he'd be on the
battlefield and he'd look down and just
collapse like that to me is just
it's just bonkers yeah we i i did you
know deployed all over the world um in
yemen afghanistan iraq pakistan libya
and a lot of the things that people deal
with in those countries they deal with
because that's the way life is
a byproduct of freedom is complacency
and it always has been because we
optimize our life in this democracy and
this sovereignty and it makes our life
really easy but it also makes us very
weak and there is a very specific
percentage of the country from my peer
group who knows what warfare is and then
there's the rest of society one of the
reasons we started fieldcraft survival
is to teach civilians about worst case
scenarios because if you train for the
worst case you're prepared for
everything in between don't train for
the best case train for the worst case
the crazy thing to me is uh
how to conf convey that experience of
actually watching uh you know violence
and trauma to an individual so they
understand why it's so important
to to be prepared
to to unders look there was a story
about a club a fire broke out and
everyone immediately ran to the door and
they all jammed themselves in it and
then i think like people died and
there's a video where a guy when
everyone's running and screaming calmly
walks to the to the fire exit in the
back next to the stage and just walks
out
you know i've always done this my whole
life and maybe it's because my dad was a
marine but or as a firefighter actually
and he would say no matter where you are
no whenever you go in a building
wherever you are know your exits and so
my whole life like we'd walk in i'm a
little kid and he'd be like where's the
fire exit now look i'm like it's right
there he goes you got it
and then i hear these stories of people
who are so unprepared and so complacent
they don't even understand how to leave
a building when the smoke alarm goes off
let me tell you a story man i worked for
fusion which is the abc univision joint
venture no longer exists
i'm in the new york office
and it was really really nice office
they they had desks and then they also
had these little diner chairs they had
set up so you could sit in a comfy
little chair to table with your friends
and talk and so i'm sitting there with
my computer and i'm with um my producer
who was working with me
all of a sudden the bright lights start
going off when full blast i grab my
computer in the plug i put under my my i
get up jump out of the table and i look
over and she's just in and i'm like come
on let's go and she's like what i'm like
the alarm's going let's go and then she
grabs her stuff and then i look over
everybody i'm like yo let's go and
there's
50 people just sitting there look at me
and then i'm like i'm waiting i get out
of the building we're on like the third
floor i go outside i'm standing outside
i get asked like what's going i'm like
the fire alarm went off you get out of
the building what do you
and then nobody else came out
fire trucks pull up this is in new york
two trucks pull up all the firefighters
jump out run inside
and then a few minutes later one by one
the employees all start walking outside
going like what's happening what's
happening and then i was like did you
guys seriously stay in the building when
the fire alarm went off and you're on it
was like a five-story building or
something like the third floor
turns out there was some kind of gas
leak or or fire threat and it was
remarkable to me that these people were
so comfortable the fire alarm literally
did not persuade them to get out of the
building that's what scares me when we
talk about all of the stuff the petrol
for conflict is that i have witnessed
people sit in the building with the fire
alarms going off full blast
before this happened this is crazy we're
in a different building the power goes
out
the speakers go on
this is an uh an emergency situation has
arisen remain calm stay in the building
and i was like nope and i got out of the
building everybody else stayed turns out
there was a there was a leak in the
basement that had made contact with the
electrical system caused a short huge
fire risk and they didn't want anybody
rushing to the doors and panicking and
leaving so they all just sat there using
battery power on their laptops and i
left the building and went to a cafe to
work i just
i've seen so much of this man
i was in ferguson
i'm with the guy he's a he's a veteran
field reporter he's he's fired fully
automatic guns he's been in war and
conflict he's got legit body armor and
they make the announcement that uh
darren wilson will not be indicted or
something like that and then all of a
sudden
we hear bang bang bang bang bang
i'm on the ground i look to my right
dude's on the ground and i'm like my man
i look to my left and there's a guy from
abc standing there looking around going
those fireworks
and i'm like get down
and then he's like what's happening i
was like do you see anybody with
fireworks no do you see guns okay dude
it's crazy to me man when you're put in
these situations and i'm not even
talking about war i'm like just street
violence riots and stuff but to see how
people act when this stuff goes down i
imagine like in the heat of the chaos
there's very little you can do to
convince un uneducated people about it
so is this why like you're doing this
now so people ahead of time like i was
thinking last night okay just i've been
thinking i've been in emergency mode for
like weeks it just strikes me like what
if there's an active shooter what if
there's a fire i i should have a plan
with my neighbors with my environment so
what are what steps from from start to
finish if someone were to experience
like an emergency a life-threatening
emergency yeah so all the things you're
describing when we talk about worst-case
scenarios whether it's natural man-made
disaster has to do with stress they're
all like like a a catastrophe is
actually a stressful event
just short in duration of time but
elevated in the actual volume of stress
that you get so a lot of people aren't
prepared for mild stress
and you know i make the joke like if
your girlfriend texts you and says hey i
saw you liking those girls uh yoga pants
videos on instagram how do you react a
lot of people were like oh what are you
talking about and they get angry and
emotional and they don't know how to
react their palms sweat
and that overreaction is a correlation
to high grade stress how you're going to
react to high grade so a lot of people
in our society they use group think as a
psychology tactic which they don't know
they're doing but it's like if that
person's not moving why would i move
right so we're all sheeple right we're
just not doing anything so the idea is
like identify the threat
observe
pay attention to what it is but like tim
said in a couple examples
physical displacement from the x or the
crisis is the best way to survive so
break your physical body up and away
create distance time and as many
obstacles as you can put in between but
because we're curious we want to catch
catch everything for the gram we're like
what is that noise is that firecrackers
let's walk out with the phone and catch
this on my story on instagram and then
get potentially shot in the face
not just that but i've seen these
veteran journalists they do no training
and they go into hostile environments
and they put everybody at risk yes it
happens all the time i've seen it too
i've seen it live
in war with journalists that were with
us sebastian younger is a good example
his one of his best friends who was a
cinematographer on restrepo when he went
was hit by an rpg in libya and killed
not saying they did the wrong thing but
that's that's the potential risk to your
life our society is very fragile very
weak and if you're not getting prepared
now then you should be when you say uh
make distance and time from the ex from
the tragedy or from the
the uh i guess emergency are you saying
like so this is a fire you want physical
distance but you also want when you say
time what is that like you want water
that'll make the fire take longer you
want to create in the distance which is
correlated to time you want to create a
gap space in getting off the x the the
proximity which a lot of the indications
of a catastrophe we sense obviously we
through sound smell taste whatever it is
we we feel it even intuition we're like
hey something might be wrong
follow your intuition one of the reasons
why so many people are getting killed
it's because we're complacent but that
relates to our laziness it's like the
idea of like you're in bed watching
netflix with your with your spouse you
hear a loud noise downstairs what do you
immediately do you write it off you're
like oh that's probably the cat uh honey
we don't have a cat oh it's well it's
the neighbor
how's it settling the house is settling
get off your ass
and physically
assess the situation so if you hear
fireworks well that's fireworks if it
sounds like gunshots start moving and
then figure it out on the on the on the
way out and then read about it on the
news but don't take the chance that
something's gonna happen and then that's
that's obviously the first part the
second part is the technical proficiency
you need and then also the inoculation
of stress most people
forget that like if i teach you to apply
a tourniquet take you three minutes i
mean it's not hard you got a pen yeah is
it a pen a belt material an actual
tourniquet that costs 29.95 on
fieldcraftsrifle.com it's not expensive
um but you get that tourniquet
what we're forgetting in technical
proficiency is there's this inoculation
suppression of stress which means you're
likely going to be in a sympathetic
nervous response fighting and fighting
your body primarily wants to move so you
have to be able to technically react and
do those things
while under stress we don't have
anything in our society besides
jiu-jitsu uh combat sports um
sports period that allow us to do that
but what are we seeing we're seeing woke
a culture making us more soft because
it's everybody gets to participation
one thing that
stuck with me for a long time is this
story i read uh i was told when i was
younger
somebody in my neighborhood these these
guys got into a fight
some guys beat up some guy
a few days later
you know a guy b beats up guy a a few
days later guy a's friends see guys b
and they run up and start wailing on and
then all of a sudden in the middle of
the pummel one of the dudes pulls out a
knife and goes one two right in the
chest of the dude they're beating up the
other two guys go whoa whoa dude dude
and pull him back like what are you
doing like we were just beating him up
they asked the guy are you okay and he's
like yeah i'm fine and he gets up and
runs turns the corner and drops dead
they hit his lung yeah and it was crazy
when uh
i learned about sucking wounds i think
that's right right how simple it would
have been to save that guy's life
relatively simple i mean i don't know
i'm not an expert on how to i know you
can do the trick with like plastic wrap
and tape on three sides but couldn't
they just like he could have like stuck
his finger in it or plugged it or
something and well it's uh so your your
chest cavity your chest wall is very
it's very
fragile to say the least you take a
puncture when in the chest you're going
to collapse a lung because the negative
pressure and your lung collapses because
it needs that pressure what you're doing
in the chest seal is you're applying it
to that laceration where you've been
compromised in your chest cavity and
it's re-establishing the balance and
that pressure what sounds like to me
that situation is he hits something in
that's vital so he said something in the
pump house he might have nicked an
artery bled internally which in that
case he would need a chest tube or he
would need you know upgraded levels of
care and there might not have been a
thing he could have done so thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 p.m and if
you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there
you